the news broke yesterday morning because
they sent around the agenda for next
week's ownership meeting and one of the
items on the agenda is approving
daniel snyder's request to exceed the
nfl's team by team debt limits so he can
buy out the 40 percent or thereabouts
held by his three limited partners who
have been trying desperately to sell for
more than a year because they don't want
to do business with daniel snyder
anymore it turned ugly there have been
arbitrations there's been litigation and
now daniel snyder acquiring the money
necessary by being permitted to go above
the debt limit put in place for every
team to borrow and buy out these guys
and the big takeaway is this chris yeah
the fact that the league is poised to
let him do it right is being interpreted
as a clear message
that however this ongoing investigation
of workplace misconduct over a period of
years with the washington football team
ends it won't end with daniel snyder
being forced to sell and you may
remember a few weeks ago there was a
leak from at least a draft report of a
recommendation from attorney beth
wilkinson that snyder be pressured
forced required to sell that's likely
not happening because of the fact that
they've empowered him to borrow the
money necessary to buy these other guys
out yeah i mean interesting uh i mean
you know all of all of it's interesting
i think the first thing i just i'd like
to ask you just is like
yeah i mean
why how do the owners how does the nfl
get behind it with like this a lot of
this stuff still pending i guess is what
i'm a little surprised by to a degree
you know i i know we've it just it seems
like the owners feel like daniel snyder
might not be as wrong as maybe we think
he is or he's been portrayed to be what
do they have info we don't go ahead tell
me i i think that
from the beginning the vibe has been
they're not going to make himself
so this isn't inconsistent
with
just the sense i've gotten the people i
know the people i talked to there's
never been
any type of a ground swell
even though he's not one of the more
popular owners i think there's a concern
yeah of throwing stones from the porch
of a glass house
of but for the grace of god go we
that they may be establishing a standard
yeah
in washington right that all of a sudden
starts getting applied to everybody and
i ain't gonna name names
but
look you're talking about billionaires
who are used to being catered to
who are used to getting what they want
when they want how they want and that
doesn't mean that anyone's crossed the
line i'm not saying that yeah but but
this is pandora's box and you don't want
to let her out is what you're saying
and that's exactly what i'm saying right
and and i remember when jerry richardson
handed the keys over he wasn't forced he
was done he didn't have any errors he
was going to give the team to see snyder
wants to keep the team because he wants
to give it to his kids richardson was
just going to end up selling it through
his estate when he died so here comes
this and it's horrifying and it's
mortifying and he has that facade of
southern gentleman the last thing he's
going to do is get into a big ugly fight
with anybody he says i'll sell the team
and what a punishment he got a couple of
billion dollars for the franchise he
founded back in 1995 for an expansion
for a hell of a lot less than that
and and and i think that
situation scared some folks
but the idea that the league would
create a precedent that it will force an
owner to sell
based upon
things that any of them could be accused
of
and then you got to go back 15 20 years
however many years and ask yourself well
who's going to come out of the woodwork
and put pressure on me now and i got to
worry about having to sell my team no
thank you we're not crossing that bridge
yeah i mean
that's makes a lot of sense mike that
you know i didn't really think of that
aspect because i was that's where i as a
just a fan and i don't get into all the
legal stuff all the time like that i
mean that's your your ballpark and
you're awesome at it i like picking your
brain about it but i just found it
curious you know i did and especially
with all you know again
the players always being held to protect
the shield protect the shield protect
the shield all that type of stuff
you know i i sometimes do find this
stuff a little hypocritical when it
comes to well chris but i know i know he
may be he may be suspended he may be
fine i mean there's been no player that
i can think of other than
the indefinite suspensions arising under
the drug policy that i strongly disagree
with even then the player can come back
right the idea of forcing an owner to
sell is a lifetime ban
and
i can't think of any player
who's had a lifetime ban ray rice had a
de facto lifetime ban because they
shoved him out and nobody would bring
him back right and frankly if he if he
was
you know
a star player at the time this all
happened he would have been back we know
how that goes right but
the the it's a it's an extreme
outcome and i don't think the owners
want to stretch the rubber band that far
because then it could potentially be
stretched that far for one of them at
some point in the future and it's just
something else to worry about what about
and i i really think that's why it's not
going to that yeah it makes a lot of
sense mike when you said it i went oh
that that's exactly what it is i mean
kind of like the light bulb went on my
head what about like the amount he paid
for the team like
is that is that looked you know for that
40 i didn't realize he only had 60 of
the team i don't know why i thought he
had a bigger percentage of the football
team but 950 million at this point is
that value what is that like well yeah
where does that look at
i saw someone else report it's 8.75 uh
either way we're talking about a 2
billion to 2.4 billion dollar total
valuation but
the minority interests aren't as
valuable as the majority interest
because what do you really have
that's one of the reasons why these guys
want it out what do you really have yeah
you don't have any control right you
don't have any voting rights you have no
path to purchasing majority interest in
the team
it's just an investment
that
lets you
hobnob with some movers and shakers when
even though you're a mover and shaker in
other industries
this piece of the team you hold doesn't
mean jack squats so those shares are
worth less than what they'd be worth on
the open market two and a half billion
dollar total valuation i think is
inaccurate i think the 60 that snyder
already held is worth a lot more and if
you can sell the full hundred to someone
at some point if that's what you choose
to do you're going to get a hell of a
lot more out of i was told by somebody
last year that i trust that the gambling
proliferation legalization
how it's going to spread all the
different ways they're going to find to
make money off of gambling is going to
result in
teams being worth between 8 and 10
billion dollars sooner rather than later
wow that's unreal i mean again i'd like
to see the washington football team kind
of get back on the right track this was
a good year for them last year 2020. i
mean as far as the team i know daniel
snyder had his own issues and you know
hopefully this can get figured out
either way but
i do like football when they're relevant
i do i've always been a fan of the
washington franchise just because i grew
up in the nfc's that's what i've seen
and i just i wonder ron rivera certainly
seems like he settled things down i'd
wish they'd move out of that dumb
stadium they are in the middle of
nowhere and get back to the dc area and
do something like that
but you know good for daniel snyder now
he controls the whole football team and
we'll see if he can get some of this
other stuff under control
and i will say this on the way to break
and this is just an expression of my
opinion i was in that stadium for an
international soccer match we went to go
see lionel messi play and all we did was
see him sit on the bench shocker that
place is a dump it is a complete and
total dump and i'm amazed it's only 25
years or so old it feels like it's been
around as long as the roman colosseum
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports